hello and welcome to this video playing
oh wow rmb oh 6 11 who have played him
once yeah this is not my favorite line
ever let's see I play something or this
one okay yes I don't fear so much I mean
why does certainly okay but I'm more
concerned about other Muslim should buy
a 4c phone yeah anyway yeah why does
playing to get to get good central
control but he gives me the pair of
bishops which admittedly um ok I am be
success if I ok t5 I can actually take
this is not a problem here I want to
play be 6 a-6 ultimately be five yeah I
think I can take this here in this
position now my control over the five is
completely sufficient here we should be
seven I can even play f5 maybe f5 is
kind of interesting ok I'll go for that
it's a little bit dicey but but
interesting if he takes it efore there's
a check on b3 this is not so great but I
thought I can take and give him this
pretty bad structure ok Queen him and to
get the pawn on f5 and then I can play
against f3 ok very quickly played here
form it makes perfect sense
okay I can take it let him take if i
take with the rook actually yeah it
makes some sense to keep queens on here
right his son king is a little bit on
the weak side
okay so your gauge 5s probably not doing
that much
okay i can take c 2 now or not hi this
is hanging ok question is do I just give
it away and put it on a salon Bishop
have six is so far more active move so
I'm going to do that I don't want to sit
passively here the bishop and the porn
if I take yeah I mean can i take it i
know i can check back wrong this week
this is why I was hesitating
you
now that that Queen on d5 is more than
more than irritating where is it going
queen bee file and then I have rugae
forever came some the trades this end
game is ok for me at least nothing
special but it's such a perfectly ok yep
ok here's a rookie aight doesn't do much
maybe rotate to him
so let's see is there something I can do
it this threaten to take c3 in case of
I'm a king it to white a cozy 3 is what
I'm trying to say beef beef I've ever
before now it's interesting let's try
that we're a position a little bit I'll
ammonius for wide I had Bishop g5 but
just create a look at three check what's
possible I still I should have seen that
young troops if I didn't play it I
should have should have considered it at
least ok so here now yeah do I trader
look
rock this out we think it's reading
helps a lot around i work till five
maybe this is something that i should
have considered yeah okay it's not not
dangerous I think a five before as my
idea it's bishop is it's a little bit
stuck the whole thing okay you want to
play route 27 now to trade
yeah a 5-2 to check in g6 would be seven
before takes Bishop takes Knight morning
takes takes yeah this is a draw I mean
check it timewise chatons a little bit
problematic but check and then you can
take with the poor now that's unlucky
that's unlucky check very stupid
ma'am okay well that was very
unnecessary to to get into this into
this thing check check I think you
cannot really do much here to be honest
this he goes sage form check check
check check grah I've heard I thought it
might be three fold I mean I'm not
expecting him to take the draw here gave
drown no it actually does it's nice yeah
wait is it is a draw but nature I
shouldn't have gone there because i
think jay i'm gonna get to shout the
ending here I should get to get to try
to win somehow and I never got there
maybe he just defended it correctly it's
of course possible we checked this him
yeah maybe now before I did since chang
chang yeah i can also do this of course
but i didn't see that he has them yeah
this is this is also thinking pretty
shiny clean drawn now because i can get
to that thing now something like that i
mean there's no inroads to my position I
can also attack myself mmm interesting
interesting stuff so here I went with
this f5 vio came and now mmm engine
wants to don't wants to go d5 that's
also interesting again I thought this is
good name maybe not I mean not good in
terms of an advantage I think we we
don't have to argue if black is ok black
it's certainly ok yeah maybe this is a
bad decision that's its fits true maybe
that's true i mean i can also do this
kind of thing taking is bad i have the
better prone structure but here check my
pieces are uncoordinated and this is
enough for him to to equalize it if i
have to play this it's probably equal I
mean my structure is better but
I cannot really use this much okay well
thanks for watching